perdez alors quand on vous parle du
retour d'indochine
vous dites n'est jamais partie parce
qu'on a fait beaucoup de fait beaucoup
de scène toujours oui oui c'est ça
pardon c'est vraiment toutes les années
90 les tournées en fait
en fait quand je dirai où est passée
indochine en fait j'étais sur scène en
france effectivement les radios les
télés nous passer beaucoup moins que
dans les années 80 mais ce qui était
plus de 16 ans a en fait ça nous a rendu
vachement service puisqu'en fait
maintenant dans les années 90 entre
guillemets les mômes
je veux dire ils sont pas ils sont pas
dupes des médias ils prennent pas ils
prennent pas tous à la lèvre et donc
effectivement les ont donné des concerts
tout le temps et petit à petit il ya
deux genres de plus en plus de gens qui
sont venus nous voir et ils sont pas
sûrs que les gens qui sont venus nous
voir nous aimait vraiment passé mais la
plus belle de votre votre come-back en
ce moment c'est plutôt un come back
médiatique parce quils sa com a mis la
tête parce qu'effectivement bon faut pas
se leurrer la mort de stéphane hains
provoqué entre guillemets encore un
capital sympathie mais ça c'est beau je
veux dire c'est comme ça et c'est vrai
que la presse maintenant trouve qui est
un phénomène parce qu'on est là quand
même depuis vingt ans et que on fait des
concerts bourré machin et où donc
lisible mais [ __ ] on a oublié de dire
que ça existait toujours et c'est vrai
que vous avez des femmes
moi je me souviens ici avec guy boucher
peggy bouchet casser la logique à la
rame avec un québécois ont porté comme
disent ils de chine
alors j'imagine que l'émission me
l'envoyer attendez vous traversez
l'atlantique en l'écoutant indochine
sakura c'est pour aller plus vite
et alors on a reçus mais d incroyable
hein t'as dit mail absolument incroyable
de gens disant mais vous n'avez pas
honte de dire du mal d'un de chine
atteignant vous êtes vraiment des femmes
vraiment des gens qui vous qui vous
défendent quoi mais je pense qu'il
ferait ils peuvent être fiers parce
qu'ils se battre il se bat tout seul en
fait respect et tout mais quand même le
groupe indochine mam a causé beaucoup de
torts dans mon adolescence un vraiment
pas bon parce que moi c'était pas s
était pas une musique sur laquelle je
dansais et dans les boums que je faisais
c'était que indochine tout le temps et
c'était vraiment la galère mois cgt dans
moi j'adore
moi j'étais dans leurs aidants durable
déjà et c'était la galère quoi je suis
désolé j'ai j'aimais bien quand même
fait venir la carte mère écoutait mais
j'étais avec des bouts et en aisance
disait [ __ ] c'est donc comme une
success est l'aventurier c'était sept
cent mille exemplaires est énorme
ensuite vous avez du succès non
seulement en france mais dans tous les
pays scandinaves
après oui alors vous avez eu un succès
fou et vous dites alors ça c'est pour ça
que j'aimerais servir je n'ai jamais
couché avec une groupie ouais j'ai dormi
avec mes joies mes regrets que tu as
vous parlais justement de dîner en suède
avec philippe manoeuvre et vous dit
qu'il avait la bave aux lèvres
vous l'avez lors ils étaient tous les
deux ans en suède vous l'avez ramené à
l'hôtel et le lendemain vous êtes dormi
avec les chinois vous n'avez pas touché
non ctv rythme lent mais ses rivaux
nettement c'était dur mais effectivement
il ya trois jeunes suédoises qui sont
venus à manger à notre table après le
concert effectivement tout le monde
avait des torticolis incroyable parce
qu'elle était quand même temps alors
qu'être mustapha bon peut-être un peu
plus jeunes mais c'est un principe donc
je les ai raccompagné chez elles
effectivement philippe manoeuvre a été
ouvert dégoûté [ __ ] mais quand ça se
fête et le lendemain ils sont venus nous
rejoindre dans un autre concert et les
ranger dans ma chance mais je ne sais
pas et vous êtes élu bon je me suis
accroché mais j'ai tenu mon slalom de
brassy par nicola sirkis
c'est à dire ouais de respect par
rapport à ça après nous rentre à paris à
lens dans souhaitent ils avaient quand
même 2000 suédoise ce soit sur de tels
crois pas
je m'attends à 2000 chédouet situe vers
faire mais c'était pas elle était en
plus on a dormi pamiers je dirais en
slip c'était encore plus dur oui comment
ça va alors maintenant vous retrouver
tout seul c'est vrai que je me retrouve
tout seul mais stéphane et moi on
s'était juré qu'on voulait passer le cap
de l'an 2000 parce que c'était plutôt
rigolo justement d'être un groupe qui
passait de siècle avec tout ce qu'on
avait enduré tout ce qu'on a fait entre
guillemets subi mais c'est à dire c'est
et donc on réussit ça et même si
effectivement il est plus là
physiquement il est là aussi donc c'est
ça va je veux dire là on vient de faire
une tournée est ce qui est incroyable
c'est que justement malgré malgré le
fait que cocon vous avez dit on croyait
disparu et cetera que l'on vient de
faire un zénith bourré à craquer de gens
entre 15 et 25 ans et ces gens là moi je
suis fier d'eux parce qu'effectivement
il aime le ce qu'on fait vraiment par
passion par sincérité est pas parce que
ça passe énormément à la radio ou par
d'autres choses